welch est mort hier le premier c'est
hautement la philosophie depuis son
origine et valoir justement ce rapport à
cela et ensuite voir un peu du côté des
grandes controverses ou de la
philosophie de la science sont
enchevêtrées et qui ont été à l'origine
de deux des grands débats scientifiques
ces artifices était à l'origine on
recommencera pas à ça de ma vie sociale
alors on va essayer de voir un peu de
foot et de la définition classique de la
philosophie est habillée telle qu'elle
se pratiquait depuis les grecs alors
redéfini à à partir je d'un certain
ouvrage de lévi la philosophie comme
étant composé de trois tâches
essentielles l'art et horia la praxis et
la sa x
le premier moment la pierre ou bien les
technologies et les sciences nous ramène
à spéculation spéculation ces mails et
des hypothèses est ensuite allé
jusqu'aux conséquences de l'hypnose est
tombé à zéro et on revient au revoir à
la contemplation et la compréhension
monde asie la question que l'on exposé
lors se pose ce serait qu'est ce que le
mot alors content de ta question puisque
le mans cela me ramène à d'autres
questions comment est il qu'ils aient
laissé à ce qu est ce qu il ait ordonné
ou est ce qu'il y ait des enjeux
est-ce qu'il est fait à partir d'un
principe d'ordre parce qu'il est calme
et indiqué que ces voix le principe de
composition de ce monde est-ce qu'il est
fait de matière ou est-ce qu'il ait eu
que deux principes un principal daniel
est un principe spirituel
[Musique]
par exemple si vous prenez la proche des
philosophes hongrie a deux notamment et
riviane dinosaures du cabinet monsieur
l'a commise consiste à expliquer le
monde à partir d'asie qui est la matière
c'est pour ça que les amis sont qui est
philosophe matérialiste ensuite donc
c'est quoi la crise at home in te dire
que oui mais c'est un ensemble d'atomes
qui se déplace dans le monde et ses atom
ont constitué les agencements ils vont
vers des moments et c'est comme si ceux
des verts et c'est le moment s'est
souvenu vente qui va se cogner à ma
fille m'a l'air aussi
se pose la question qu'est ce que le
monde qui laisse à son dieu à partir de
quel principe il est fait vous pourrez
aussi trouver une autre manière de notre
approche que l'apo c'est la faulx
actuelle consiste à expliquer le mot art
de presse
biarritz est mais il ya aussi à notre
principe immatériel spirituel si nous
prenons la proche de plateau par exemple
il nous dit qu'il ya un an sensible mais
que derrière ce sens il ya un monde
la terrifie auquel on accède par
l'expliqué par la maison se trouvait la
vision ils sont les noirs ce qu'est ce
que ce fait sous le monde puisque
l'univers est payé à tes droits vous
pouvez par exemple
tel est lé célèbre justement pour
dévorer de crète il va expirer manque
aux mails en régie par des lois
universelles et d'ailleurs il a été l'un
des premiers à mettre en évidence le
rôle de l'egypte cité notamment à partir
de cette année lyon comme et mobilier de
lance la question qu'est ce que le monde
mohamed assis à notre question
c'est la question qui porte sur l'offre
alors si on essayait m'en disent
également
cela implique aussi qu'on essaie de
comprendre si voilà puisque le
philosophe c'est un homme c'est un être
humain qui parmi les hommes dans science
intérieur sur l'homme
on va essayer de s'interroger sur toi à
s'interroger sur ses instincts ses
désirs mais aussi ses autres facultés
tels que la raison l'imagination et les
sens
l'adhésion sur l'offre implique aussi de
s'interroger sur sa condition est
toujours en tête
elle avait lui aussi salué le rejet sur
la vie dans la cité sur les noirs
sociale comment nomme vie en société et
enfin une question essentielle si le
philosophe sa terreur sous le monde
si le pilote ap50 sur l'homme alors elle
va aussi s'interroger sur les conditions
qui lui permet de connaître en bleu
c'est à dire qu'il doit s'interdire
question les flammes étaient autrement
dit quels sont les moyens qui nous
permettent de connaître les sens la
raison l'imagination
les rapports entre les sens et
l'imagination et c'est à partir que la
première étage on va accéder à un coût
deuxième tâche qui est la praxis
étymologiquement ralison endroit et ont
bondi action il s'agit aussi n'ont pas
réellement de l'action directe mais
encore une théorie de l'action alors
c'est quoi la raque 6 la praxis consiste
à répondre à la question comment bien
agi dans ce no comment bien se comporter
donc c'est une question qui porte sur la
morale et sur l'éthique
si vous prenez l émission de les doses
les deux ça concerne le gameplay et les
nous sommes ainsi l'éthique nous renvoie
au caractère et aux vertus dans mon
premier étage une question qui porte sur
le savoir sur la connaissance des
héritages qui porte sur la théorie de
l'action ce qui est essentiel dans cette
définition la philosophie c'est bien à
bord entre les des plages
pourquoi parce que notre compréhension
du mans notre compréhension de l'homme
pas le donner à appliquer certaines des
lobbys de l'action morale de la
connexion enfin la relation entre la
première à deuxième tâche nous renvoie à
la finalité de la ville aux offices qui
est la série la zai l'aise c'est une
relation justement en les la baignade
c'est à dire une cohérence entre notre
connaissance entre le savoir et entre
l'éthique donc la sagesse ne s'agit pas
il ne s'agit pas le tout de connaître
savoir mal de choses
il s'agit de trouver un équilibre et une
cohérence entre notre connaissance et
notre manière réagi afin de trouver
notre place
donc ce monde notre notre bonheur le
rapport annuel par rapport aux autres et
par rapport à la nature
donc à partir de cette démission
on voit bien que à l'origine il ya un
rabot est essentielle en la philosophie
et la science se sont
pratiquement indissociables est
actuellement mis en vente la science
même si on le fait par arrêté motivé au
clip on voit aussi c'est très important
d'associer la science à la question
d'éthique si vous prenez par exemple les
technologies la question de la
technologie mais toujours très social
sur moral de questions et problèmes
l'usr comment vers le mondial comment
éviter des mauvaises vial la technologie
donc à partir de là on va l'essayer
droite du côté de le 17e chèque à partir
du xviie siècle
il ya eu de grands débats qui sont à la
fois philosophique est à la fois
scientifique et qui ont contribué à
l'édification du servoir modèle alors on
va laisser le voir autrement
du côté des gars alors qu'on disait de
résumer les choses en disant qu'il y a
ces débats là et engager à partir des
ouvrages essentiels qui ouvrage les
cards déclare-t-il aux docks
rationaliste du xviie siècle cette
courageuse ou de m
alors justement qui est intéressant ou
noir qui est gérée pour oublier la
raison et chercher à les limiter dans
les sciences il y avait les yeux liés en
1627 c'est que dans la première édition
cet ouvrage n'est pas un ouvrage
indépendante philosophie c'est à lepage
qui est des services
à trois rennais sow mais sans indication
la v2 de descartes et dvd sont a dit au
pire
naughty dbo et là je m'étais donc on
voit que cet ouvrage qui nous ont fiq a
été écrit comme l'introduction des
ouvrages que je me dis ou à des ouvrages
d'optique sa charge des cas n'est pas
seulement philosophe c'est un philosophe
mathématicien est aussi physicien
donc on va essayer de voir du côté de
deux grands débats premier débat s'est
tenu des bars le rationalisme et
l'organisme réaliste le deuxième débat
c'est le débat entre le mécanisme est
élevé pénalise deux premiers dira il
s'agit de ne combat on va voir à jour
des cartes donc des cartes et dit un
philosophe nationaliste
qu'est ce que ça veut dire un philosophe
rationnelle qu'est ce que ça veut dire
être rationaliste ça veut dire que la
thèse principale la méthode de la
connaissance offre sur cette thèse c'est
que la connaissance provient
essentiellement de la raison alors c'est
quoi la région
la raison est considérée comme une
faculté qui permet qui nous permet de
connaître à partir d'un enchaînement de
causalité c'est à dire que la raison
c'est la capacité à conduire des
enchaînements correct entre cause est
fait de telle manière à constituer des
connaissances corée par exemple le
contraire de la raison ça pourrait être
la superstition dans la mesure
relationnel
établi des rapports de causalité
totalement à l'aise à yang si vous
prenez et si vous prenez une attitude
superstitieuse qui consiste à se dire
aussi en rencontre une personne le matin
risque de passer une sale journée mais
c'est d'être le lien entre une personne
et un événement or on n'y a aucun
fondement à cette relation
donc le rationalisme c'est essayer de
faire une démarche déductive mais dans
un sens plier côte alors ensuite cela me
dit aussi que cela consiste à affirmer
que dans le réel
il y a un certain nombre qui est caché
mais s'il ya un désordre apparent dans
l'eau mais elle qui es tu qui est qui
est dû à ceux qui barrent aveugle et au
sens qui va inonder me sens derrière ces
désordre apparent il y à un principe
principe de l'ordre et ce principe
d'ordre peut le découvrir grâce à notre
présent donc brésil voilà l'image dgac à
yaoundé car kia justement travaillé sur
les principes des pratiques d'aluminé en
principe de rotation des lumières il a
vu là cheval de séparation au peuple en
résidence aux résidents
ah qu'est ce qui est important et fiable
tout à fait ce que l'on constate c'est
que le rayon est considérée comme une
oie abstraite dans un espace je médite
kraft d'anglure rayon est complètement
abstrait 2 de cette dimension de la
chaleur de de la couleur de sa
consistance lumineuses etc
le rayon est réduit à un segment de
droite et c'est ça un peu la démarche
nationaliste c'est de transformer le mot
on ne laisse pas géométriques et on des
lois complètement race humaine à partir
d'un principe qui existe dans l'autre
raison qui nous permet de connaître
alors comment se fait la démarche des
cas la démarche des cartes c'est la
méthode de la détection et de la
détection consiste à enchaîner
justement les certitudes on va essayer
d'aller une certitude en certitudes à un
enchaînement de la raison alors le le
problème qui se pose ici c'est la
question des principes chrono il faut
bien commencer quelque part
si on enchaîne les connaissances et city
ont fait le chemin inverse à se
retrouver au départ on ne peut pas
raconter en année c'est ce qu'on appelle
les classes ce qu'on appelle les actions
ont été menées
ce sont des principes qui sont on appris
par avion sont des principes
si vous prenez par exemple à l'espace
étudiant content dit que par le seul par
rapport à ne passe qu'une seule droit
parallèle bras données c'est vers
l'action ça veut dire que
le problème ici consiste pour des cartes
à partir de principes qui sont évidents
et de continuer le raisonnement et des
cars est arrivé même à dire que même si
je suis pas sûr de la véracité de ces
principes
si je fais un raisonnement alors le
résultat peut être l'autre camp s'est
construit et la i10 de lidl
[Applaudissements]
donc la critique de l'utl consiste à vis
des principes élémentaires pour tista se
dire que qu'il faut faire la différence
entre les hypothèses et les principes
tant qu'on n'a pas soumis l'hypothèse
d'un protocole expérimental de
vérification alors on peut dire qu'il
s'agit d'un principe mais laissait
plutôt minimoys
donc qu'est ce qu'il faut faire on en
attendait c'est de donner des hypothèses
on va essayer d'établir un protocole
expérimental de vérification et ensuite
on va faire des hypothèses des principes
comme par exemple les principes
uniquement deux nuls donc la proche de
descartes le rationalisme jupe et la
proche du mythe hall la valeur et
l'importance de l'expérience
les middleton
alors les limites de newton en bas ou si
ça fait que que finalement newton est
lui-même tombé dès septembre et lui j'ai
de l'expérience
c'est à dire que newton a toujours
considéré que le temps était uniforme et
qu'il était un variant qu'il était
indépendant des revers deux élus j'ai
c'est que le buteur reste aussi dans un
espace petit tient et qui reste site
dans les actions de l'espace culture
donc par l'asie les nouveaux débats de
ce fait sa valise est à refonder des
actions à travailler du côté des actions
donc premièrement on va revoir actionne
qui part seul au but
for me tais du temps on va voir que le
temps est relatif par ailleurs aussi on
va travailler sur vos espaces nombre qui
tient ce qui va donner de nouveaux
actionne qui vont donner de nouveau
résolument nouvelle théorie scientifique
notamment la relativité restreinte
radeau relativité générale
alors je termine rapidement sur le
baiser les bars c'est un débat qui a
joué un rôle très important dans la
biologie
c'est le débat entre le mécanisme et le
stent alors quand on le voit on retrouve
une approche mécanisme alors c'est pas
le mécanisme nommé réaliser une action à
partir de laquelle le monde est perçue
conçu comme étant une machine et par
extension des êtres vivants
araya aussi pour être considérés comme
des machines fête des rois et ses
ouvrages la france à transmettre le
mouvement dire qu'un enchaînement de
causalité motifs alors et jeanneret
l'approché des quarts c'est la procédure
le dk c'est de considérer les cartes et
celui qui a considéré les animaux comme
étant des banshee on est on est on est
comparé à désorienter
par contre quand il va traiter de
l'homme il va considérer que l'homme
possède encore corps fonctionne
exactement comme il m'a dit exactement
comme les animaux mais qu'il a une
pensée et que cette pensée n'est pas que
les sharks complètement au mécanisme
ce qui est intéressant dans ce débat
c'est que petit à petit on va tout
intégré dans le mécanisme
parce que si vous preniez la mouche de
quand il va considérer que la
reproduction la vie comme étant un
principe les reproductions de
régénération et charcot
alors que par la suite je revenais sur
ça premièrement vous avez la maîtrise et
ensuite la science moderne qui va
expliquer l'âme c'est à dire la pensée à
partir d'un fonctionnement pour
totalement matérialiste et mécaniste si
vous prenez la raison ce schéma on
explique la pensée et l'âme à partir de
bois à partir du sénat veut à partir des
normes à partir d'un mouvement la
déplétion à partir de l'électricité et
c'est qu'on n'est plus dans sa on est
totalement dans un principe mécanisme
pourrait expliquer là mais la passe est
mais aussi la reproduction de la vie et
même la régénération de la vie va petit
à petit être expliqué par un principe
mécaniste il va voir par exemple on
avait les mêmes l'est qui comme croire
ce système lors du conflit des parents
fonctionnement ben laurie il faut chaud
me lève à l'est et oblige positions
pronazies milieux sensibles les longs
cerveau car je lisais un évangile
la cellule est bien une machine nord
même la cellule finalement qui
n'arrivait pas y échapper aux principes
du mécanisme va être aussi considéré
comme un mécanisme donc en conclusion
ces démarches la halle et dans un dans
l'intention de renouer les contacts
entre
sophie les différents champs du savoir
parce que j'estime que c'est ça va être
allongée l'essentiel justement pour
comprendre à la fois approfondir la
compréhension de savoir mais aussi pour
produire de la connaissance et je vous
remets zh